[Music]
hi I'm Josh I'm Ollie and these are our
favorite snacks
[Music]
wow oh God okay this uh is my comfort
snack we're starting out with maybe the
blandest food in existence the
ironically named Rich tea okay because
it is neither rich nor made of tea it's
a biscuit I can't believe you put these
on your list rich I mean I can't believe
it actually
oh rookie the reason I like these is
it's blandness
and that might be confusing to you at
home but we eat a lot rich food that's
true for the videos that we make when I
get home I have a cup of tea oh you just
you're just putting that on the floor
wow we've been in Hollywood for five
minutes
okay clear this up for me
please tell us about your favorite snack
the rich tea this is basically all
texture I like to get home I have a cup
of tea at the end of the day yes I don't
want anything going on in my mouth this
is like the most stereotypically British
snack you can possibly imagine
it's like crunchy
paper flavored
biscuit glorious
all right
now we're talking okay now we're talking
this is a real biscuit
I I agree this is an elite biscuit you
cannot go wrong
[Music]
now for the viewers at home this is
basically I suppose it's like an oatmeal
biscuit yeah uh with milk chocolate on
one side before we try this though there
is an essential accompaniment for a
chocolate hobnob and that is of course a
cup of English breakfast tea
let's have a cup of tea please thank you
so much I feel at home we might be in
Hollywood right now but we could be
you could be in any British person's
house yeah
[Music]
that is the Taste of Home it is good
that is good and then this is where it
gets exciting chocolate hobnob dip in
there
the oat biscuit is strong enough to
maintain structural Integrity but the
chocolate on the top melts a little bit
[Music]
um
that hot damn it's fantastic it really
is
[Applause]
you can tell they Source these in
America yeah because it says lays on
them in the UK we have what's called
Walkers it has an identical logo yeah
it's actually a British company that was
bought by lays in the 80s wow and then
ladies were like you know what you don't
get to keep your logo you're having our
logo okay you do get to keep your name
also interestingly in the UK so many
crisps are green man you're getting some
serious insights
now uh you are an absolute fiend for
some salt and vinegar oh my gosh we
travel quite a lot filming videos back
and forth around the world and before we
go away I always without fail buy three
or four packs of salt vinegar wrists in
the airport this is I would say this is
like the most traditionally British
flavored crisp I'm presuming it
originates from what we do to chips with
fish and chips basically cover it in
salt and then vinegar it's great yeah I
mean I can't complain
oh
oh yes
I knew you were gonna like this your
choices are better than my choices
this is why I always let you order in
the restaurant this is true I never
order anything in there that is true now
this is a tonic's caramel wafer biscuit
I feel like this is an old school snack
it's been around for a long time and it
looks like it doesn't it but if it ain't
broke don't fix it exactly more than
seven million of these biscuits are made
and sold every week
every week every week if you walk into
uh I guess like a school Tuck Shop or
you know a corner shop or whatever you
don't really see these being sold like
by individually individually but every
Supermarket will have stacks of them and
I feel like every British house I go to
has some of these in the cupboard you
your house always has something that's
covered I think most of the time I eat
Caroline because it's at your house
can't go wrong
oh thin layer of chocolate
wafer in the middle that's held together
all throughout with caramel
um
seven million
oh I believe it yeah
my route
The Humble dip dab yeah again yeah it
looks like something that was
manufactured a hundred years ago yes
that's true it probably was in some form
you are I think the only adult that I
know that still eats these I didn't give
up
but uh you know
sherbet powder the lollipop is included
inside the bag I mean it is sour it's
very sweet that must have sent me
absolutely bananas as a child yeah my
wife gives me these for Christmas
I'm not lying
I don't know why I'm surprised by that
no but somehow I still am
okay no way final snack uh from my side
you make great choices man I'm telling
you these are good these are good these
are the Bucky crisps these are shindang
dong says in English hot spicy Korean
snack they're based on a very
traditional Korean street food called
now we have tried a lot of snacks from
all over the world on our Channel
of all the snacks I tried from
everywhere I think these are the one
thing that if I open a bag
I know it's it's game over they're often
basically impossible to open like this
but they come with like a little
serrated edge so you can slide it open
down the side and at this point I mean
the decisions made up for you you're
committed you have to finish the whole
thing because what are you gonna do the
sweet they're spicy they're salty it's
damaged the cover all bases they're so
good
we saved the best till last okay this is
I love this I absolutely love these we
started we're ending as we began people
are gonna think I'm trolling but no you
know that I'm actually not this is my
go-to snack of course of course the cars
table water cracker I think we call them
biscuits in the UK oh yeah we do we call
them water biscuits water biscuits which
what is or table water biscuit Ollie
because it sounds like it's a biscuit
that tastes like table water it well I
think that's attributing it too much
flavor
like I said earlier we eat a lot very
rich food so when I get home a
comforting thing is to eat something
that I know just can can do me no harm
Taste of nut you know this is an
absolute freaking pacifist of Abyss you
know it's going down there and it is not
causing any trouble you know it doesn't
really do anything it does make your
mouth very dry
um so again you have that with a couple
would you have that with a cup of tea
[Music]
you are I think just the greatest
example of the British palette
foreign
[Music]
for having us today it was it was a very
nice experience I thoroughly enjoyed
myself thank you for watching and if you
want to see us have a little British
Minds blown by food from the rest of the
world with real flavor then come check
us out on Jolly and uh in the meantime
we'll see you soon wait well that's our
channel oh yeah do we not do that on
this channel I don't know I thought that
was just like our theme we'll see you
first we Feast soon no that does not
work damn it oh my gosh
[Music]